[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport rapport
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast unser top
leichtathlet weltspitze im diskuswerfen
lukas weißhaidinger und ich freue mich
sehr dass bei uns hier sein kann lukas
du hast jetzt bewegte wochen hinter dir
es geht auch in der vorbereitung schon
wieder los mit dem großen ziel tokio
dass ein ganzer plan ist ja über den
kopf geworfen worden wie hat sich bei
dir im endeffekt ganze pandemie und der
ganze stress ausgewirkt
alle andere an die danke für die
einladung ist ja sehr positiv ja ich war
natürlich wie bei jedem anderen ganze
situation mit der muss man sehen beträgt
finden wir finden welche wege zu machen
die persönliche werk merkt was mir in
der zeit vom look dann wo es mir
aufgegangen ist
aber im großen und ganzen war dies nur
20 20 nach der verschiebung wieder ist
wieder unter schlucken habt ihr
eigentlich ein schönes jahr zum
durchschnaufen jura wo man damals sehr
viel mit kämpfen wochen mit kinder und
batterien aufladen für die olympischen
spiele
du hast relativ rasch vielleicht auch
rascher als andere dann wie sich auf das
nächste jahr sozusagen gestellt und hast
die saisonplanung umgeändert was hast du
da genau gemacht was anders war als
andere diskuswerfer die vielleicht noch
auf wettkämpfe gehofft haben
international was er dann doch nicht
alles immer so toll funktioniert hat
mehrere aspekte damals verloren man
verstehen dass mit der leichtathletik
sehr lange vorbereitungszeit haben wir
schon erfahrung man meistens im oktober
so nah waren wir noch gut da olympische
spiele haben oder größer ist ein
höhepunkt dann kommt dazu dass eben mit
corona haben wir haben die karten
schauen was im herbst morgen gegen ein
fallschirm wo ist der dritte punkt war
natürlich der verschiebung für die
ganzen höhepunkt der sprich olympia und
da weg merkt für mich es ist mentaler ja
ob vorher einfach einfach reduziert noch
sein okay nächstes jahr wird es nichts
mit
internationaler präsenz caron ist in
unserer gesellschaft
wir müssen den höhepunkt für die
olympischen spiele auf 2120 verschieben
und dort einfach die persönlich geschaut
dass er möglichst schnell umstellen
dieses jahr so nehmen wir sie eben kommt
sprich einfach wie es lockerer sind mit
keinen internationalen starts rechnen
wir haben haben dann sehr für die heim
wettkämpfe gemacht für mich war danach
von seiten der raf das ist die
internationale leichtathletik verband
eaa mit den schwerpunkten und die
sicherheit nicht kommt das manöver zum
beispiel noch ein ungarn tschechien dass
da nichts passieren
die leichtathletik funktioniert da
endlich funktioniert die usa dass man
athleten und design erleichtert die
geben sehr viel ruf den hotels
aufgeteilt sein und nur weil irgendwann
schauen wir mal 1500 meter läufer beim
handwerk legen einen positiven test hat
brauchen wir die zehn druck dann in
quarantäne gehen
deswegen erwarte ich für mich relativ
schnell abgeschlossen wir haben es dann
sogar anders gemacht wir haben die
wettkämpfe früher wieder erlaubt waren
haben wir sehr rasch wettkämpfe gemacht
haben wir sehr rausgeschaut wenn man
möglichst weit werfen weil man etwas wie
schon mal herbst ganz jahr schaut und
dass wir irgendein höhepunkt haben haben
wir geschaut da in schwechat meetings
brauchen wir schon noch mal zum
höhepunkt werden einfach so nehmen wie
es kommt und dass ein sprecher wird ja
auch gut funktioniert ist da auch im
hinterkopf dass man vielleicht wenn es
dann irgendwie in richtung tokio gibt
dass man zumindest eine aktuelle
leistung auch vorweisen kann und auch
für sich selber die sicherheit hat ich
kann gerade weiter werfen auch wenn
vielleicht die beste leistung oder die
höhepunkte wird schon eineinhalb jahre
her sind ist das etwas was da auch eine
rolle spielt in der planung beim
diskuswerfen ist natürlich so dass man
ist dass man wiederum so dass wir guter
wein
und ja natürlich es ist immer gut aber
man muss einfach wettkämpfe machen was
anderes für training und vor dem haus
brutal wie ich da mal jedes jahr mit
kämpfe rot weil diese andere mentale
einstellung ist wenn man nichts am
wettkampf geht s bahn zu sagen sie waren
trainiert ist ablauf wird im frühsommer
deswegen ist ganz wichtig da man ist
jedes jahr und die athleten die
möglichkeit ergibt wie auch immer die
situation und ist da man irgendwo ich
meine wettkämpfe macht wie dem
ausschauen
und ja das war hundertprozentig ganz
wichtiger pro jahr dazu sagen muss dass
die wurst der form habe ich will frauen
waren weit werfen muss schon dass wir
nächstes jahr in berlin fehler vor
diese sicherheit die du hast die kommt
ja nicht einfach so die die hast du ja
aufgebaut
erster guter leistungen den zweitens
durch ganz penibel planungen oder sieht
man auch dass du sagst mir ich kann mir
das nicht leisten was ich da zehn tage
in quarantäne gehen nur weil jemand
irgendwo positiv ist und auch wenn du
denn den schutz sozusagen des
weltverbandes den fehlenden subjektiv
gesehen ansprichst ist das auch etwas
was dich vielleicht auszeichnet diese
planung die dann auch die sicherheit
gibt
die planung und die start gehen ich
glaube das habe ich schon ein bisschen
auch von meinem trainer vom träger hügel
der weltklasse athlet war ein bisschen
mitbekommen und gelehrt bekommen denkt
dass dies immer den athleten für die
sicherheit gibt planungssicherheit aber
was man diese und diese machen kann
wir nehmen jetzt einmal 10.000 würfe im
jahr zusammen dann weiß man dann mal
weiß gesund die damals wichtigste dann
kann man mit einer dauerleistung eine
sichere ich meine natürlich für gewisse
weiten zum x-ten mal wieder glück dazu
aber glück kann man minimieren der
kroate arbeit und ich denke wenn man
diese so zusammen rechnet dann wo es mal
ok hat conny funktioniert und heck korn
werfen und das hast du heuer eben sehr
sehr oft national gemacht also in
österreich bei verschiedensten
wettkämpfen wie war der
unterschiedlichen du bist diamond league
gewohnt du bist weltmeisterschaft und
europameisterschaft olympische spiele
gewohnt
es ist ja dann doch was anderes wenn man
auf den heimischen leichtathletik
anlagen wird und wahrscheinlich vor
wenig zuschauern weil die ganzen
maßnahmen in der überall gegolten haben
mit der hygiene vorschriften wie hat
sich das angefühlt so der kontrast
letzte saison wahnsinnig erfolgreich so
viele tolle dinge erreicht und dann
jetzt vor heimischen publikum werfen zu
können weil es die einzige möglichkeit
ist wie ist es dir damit gegangen es war
im frühjahr nur ganz so komisch gefühlt
also man hat dabei die ersten wettkämpfe
wieder zuschauer zu lassen
man hat dann ja morgen ist ein weg für
den spitzensport das hört man seinen weg
wo betrifft die wenigsten menschen und
in dem für unbedingt einfach so da
mittwoch schaut darauf stand heute und
ja es mag merkt dass für jeden irgendwie
anders weil es war einfacher situation
für jeden wo man hustet er die harmony
gold aber trotzdem von von wettkampf zu
wettkampf sanna die zuschauerzahlen
stiegen wenn man merkt dass man mit
einem gewissen konzept kann man das
machen kann man die sicherheit
gewährleisten und dann ist schon lang
son vida schon wettkampfrhythmus
allgemeine komma usa absolut schön war
dass man wirklich vor heimischen
publikum werfen kann
und nun ist auf der hand wolfen bei die
bei meetings und die stadt wesentlich
spaß macht haben sie damals sogar
meistens nicht mio
die heim wettkämpfe immer so mit man
kommt von internationalen wettkampf hat
zwar doch dazwischen macht dann
heimgekommen und fliegt man schon wieder
zum nächsten und her weil es ist einfach
so davon so dass die highlights von jahr
hat viel spaß gemacht obwohl also zu
sagen was da sie bei den wettkämpfen
immer brutal nervös weise wo er ist da
sie waren in oberösterreich wird dass
sie genauso nervös wie man bei der
wm-qualifikation habe das kann sich
vorstellen wenn wir das erste woran
liegt das
mein glaube das liegt daran dass jeder
sportler einfach von irgendwas
angetrieben wird motivation und bei mir
ist es einfach so dass im fall heim
publikum immer von der besten seite
sie haben mich wirklich darauf
dominieren weichert und wirklich die
letzte woche so weit kann man
diskuswerfen und dafür mehr wirklich
angesprochen besten seite zeigen und da
ist natürlich der druck dann extrem hoch
und die freunde und familie zu
erschüttern noch ein bisschen mehr und
man dann mal klar die nicht zuschaut
dann ein messer und sage ich mal
und der international ist dann so da hat
ja schon unterwegs man hat die flügel
hat die kurzen hotelaufenthalte da geht
alles sehr rasch man auch die wettkämpfe
die sich so ein bisserl mehr beruf und
da waren wir auf mich ein bisschen mehr
spaß freizeit und genießen und zu den
gewissen natürlich kommt nervosität
es ist einfach anders meint aber dass er
sagen dass die universität die ihr vom
typ jetzt etwas bringt oder ist das dann
eher für dich hinderlich also brauchst
du das um deine beste leistung zu
schaffen
die schlechtesten wettkämpfe san diego
wo man mit einer geschichte eingeht ohne
man sagt es macht mir komme was wolle
finde ich persönlich nervosität dieser
positive anspannung für mich beschreibt
an ihre nervosität sondern jeder
sportler kennt ist die weichen knie wo
man sich sagt er habe vielleicht nur
kniebeugen gemacht aber wo soll ich das
jetzt einfach diese adrenalin und das
braucht man ich brauche jeden wettkampf
ohne dem wenig funktioniert man nicht
und ich glaube wenn wir dies nicht macht
dann selber mit sport daraufhin weiter
dann ist dies nehme das ist der sport
der eigentliche worum es dabei geht das
wirklich mist einmal ausgibt weil man
diesen als ein indikator ob noch genug
passieren gehört dahinter steckt oder
nicht jetzt weiß man von dir eben dass
du nicht nur ganz genau planst und alles
wirklich perfekt durchgestylt ist man
weiß auch dass du neue wege beim
training ist dass du dir eigene
trainingsmaschinen baust wurde aber wir
für ganz genau nach stellen kannst auch
ohne den diskus zu werfen
wie kann sich das ganz genau vorstellen
was hast du alles so für geräte bei dir
immer trainingsstandort in der südstadt
stehen ich habe mir haben so fischer
wir haben zum beispiel für die
regeneration hammer laser ultraschall
kette becken habe da wirklich dann für
die regeneration mit der möglichst
kühlen kann
wir haben ktg haben wir an dieser
krafttrainings gerät speziell für diskus
wir haben ein lifter das ist nur relativ
das neueste gerät oder das neueste
gadget das ist wirklich für fürs
krafttraining und wo sie jetzt hoffe
dass man ein bisschen ausbauen weil die
biomechanik es gibt ein neues system wo
man wirklich die bewegung ist wie
diskuswerfen machen kann und dann ein
sehr kurzer zeit spricht 10 15 sekunden
auswertung wurde in der biomechanik und
das wäre ein game changer tanja so
wollen die vorstände hätten und die
guten bewerten könnte er die schlechten
bewerten und warum dass der schlächter
warum der stick wird war das macht
greger vorhaben einer geister der
biomechanische fuchs sage mal der haut
für waren wurf oder zwei nächte braucht
also wirklich tausend klicks wo man
wirklich mit seiner kamera wo es
wirklich wo ich in zeitlupe auf jemand
gerne wirklich extrem für bild für
bildung um immer klick wochen muss genau
auf dem diskus handgelenk schulter hüfte
dann knie sprunggelenk und dass man
einfach us wochen dass die biomechanik
funktionieren und die es wert sind muss
man mit die kameras machen könnten und
dies wird dann natürlich hat vorteil
verschaffen weil ich weiß zum beispiel
daran hält der muss jetzt der
weltmeister warnt und sicherlich vom
körper bei warner vor die besten
diskuswerfer ist die bis jetzt gibt aber
hier geben hat der hat eine spannweite
von 23 20
es gibt den jungen slowenen der hamam
sparte wo zwei meter hoch sein
heute danke so da so sind im bereich das
jamaikaner und habt zwar mit 0 28 meter
mehr an spannweite ist in der weiter auf
dem diskus bezogen ein meter silber
technik und dass man wohl sagen dass wir
müssen nochmal für
mehr bis am morgen wie die dass man
schlecht ankommt und das ist das was uns
antreibt warum er so genau planen
warum man zum beispiel dass ktg machen
warum man hier die verschiedensten
trainingsstätte einfach an was brauchen
sonst können wir vorne mitspielen weil
die leichtathletik ist trotzdem eine
grund sport worten wir haben wir nur den
zwei kilo diskus sonst nix
medientechnisch da nix behelfen und vor
dem her müssen mir persönlich die
bezeichnung regelmäßig die zwar im team
der weltklasse diskuswerfers die wo es
die techniker seien ja doch einfach
schauen aber möglichst präzise hat eine
technik arbeiten und dass mir die physik
ins spiel bringen also ich glaube
dagegen ist man jemand zwar wurden wir
schauen da man die die physik mit ein
paar nimmt einen diskus ist fangen da
beim ansturm war ein wurf anschaut sieht
man schauen also anders anschwingen wie
andere also damit zusammen dass ich der
einzige bin da wo es den diskus verlust
und meine gegenfrage warum machst du das
nicht versucht zu erklären weil vorteil
eigenheit aber wir schauen natürlich
dass man da einen vorteil irgendwie
verschlafen und daniel suter ist schauen
da mal nächstes jahr flogen das ist das
ist der anspruch da muss man so wir
haben haben warum man jeden tag am
trainingsplatz steigern und ja wir
werden irgendwann wissen wir werden also
werfen
hoffen wir mal dass deine konkurrenten
jetzt aber nicht zu hören wie du jetzt
deine geheimnisse verraten hat dass ich
versuche das so bis auf mundart dreht
man das ist nicht wahr dass
internationale übersetzung schaffen
hast du genau sagen wollte ich glaube
man merkt wirklich wie penibel und wie
genau ihr versucht da jetzt den
spannweiten nachteil über die technik
auszugleichen und dann vielleicht daraus
auch ein vorteil zu haben wenn man weiß
wie genau ja da drin jetzt jetzt ist die
frage seid ihr die einzigen die dann
eigens hergerichteten geräte haben damit
sie beim training all das optimieren
oder trainieren die anderen doch auch in
diesem bereich auf einem ähnlichen
niveau also da man versteht warum wir
das machen
die am spannweite ist er sehr wichtiger
indikator für diskuswerfen
ich habe gegner zum beispiel der martin
wierig der ist zwei meter auch großen
ein sieg her
meine hand 671 bewusst so die glänzen
diskus werfer in der weltspitze dazu für
sand über zwei meter drei große
olympiasieger 2 meter mit 5 der an
sportwetten und das an ihm hoch
dies seien keine variablen es ist
einfach so wie sie das physik und wann
wir es mit unserer aufbau wie man die
richter den maximalen peak einen diskus
eine bringt müssen wir schauen dass man
möglichst viel investieren wenn man mehr
ps sozusagen in die berechnung basiert
er ruft vom 7 es war am 7 es müssen
migrieren da mal über 67 meter werfen
und die sauna kann dem variablen und auf
die frage zurück zum kommt das andere
ahorn
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht weil die
planer nicht so wirklich aus also
hörensagen steht in deutschland nur
gerät ob die jetzt wirklich drauf
trainieren oder nicht ist ohne urteil
ja da sagt keiner wirklich dass tui da
wo wir so geräten sieg der vom 1
kategorie fotos nennt es ist mir sehr
wichtig weil es kein lust darauf dass
man irgendeinen report und den vorteil
dass ländern verspielen also in dem
sinne wirklich auch fast schon eine
wissenschaft und wie das gesagt dass du
einen vorteil zu haben
auch ein bisschen geheimnis als wirklich
top secret wie man es geschafft hat
diese leistungen auch zu wahren du hast
auch schon angesprochen dass du nächstes
jahr eben vor deinen konkurrenten stehen
möchte jetzt was du in rio sechster in
der zwischenzeit hast du mit deinem
gemacht europameisterschaften
weltmeisterschaften gehört zur absoluten
weltspitze
wenn du mit dieser sicherheit in die
spieler nächstes jahr hingehst und wenn
du mal aus blender ist die gesamte
unsicherheit der der situation
was glaubst oder was fühlst du ist für
dich an dem tag ist möglich wie gehst du
da mental in dieser
station ist eine gute frage diskuswerfen
ist mit mars partner also 60 meter 60
meter der diskus hat immer zwei kilo
egal wo auf der wirt die kann man nicht
beeinflussen das ist okay die werdohler
schlecht ich kann da schauen dass sie
besser wird wie die un vor dem her ist
das ziel einfach am tag iks möglichst
weit zu werfen und es muss vorher sei
jetzt im aufbau schon ist darauf
ausgerichtet dass jeden tag ich nächstes
jahr ein tokioer möglichst weit wie
jetzt regnet oder 40 grad und hoher
luftfeuchtigkeit oder passieren dürfte
timmers dort den topf vom herd nehmen
muss dort schaut man sein diskus
möglichst weit werfen
das versuche einfach alle daran hier
jeden tag daran dass immer verbessern
und jener der meinung dass die
goldmedaille an einem guten tag
sicherlich über 70 meter her geht und
das muss das ziel sein
roddicks 70 meter werfen kann ja ob es
dann so wie es natürlich ist er rechts
restrisiko mit glück ist immer dabei
bewusst einfach in der millisekunde us
zahnpasten muss aber muss man natürlich
nicht vergessen darf ist ich hoffe dass
zweimal bewiesen dass ich es klappt zu
qualität in einem sport disney muss sie
leicht macht es die quali schaffen und
dann fangen mit die besten diskuswerfer
der welt messen und kann erneut um
medaillen kämpfen aber natürlich das
ziel ist eine medaille zu machen aber
dieses ziel haben drei anderen antworten
und zehn die wussten erkennen ja weil
sie fährt mit zehn leitung und drei
männer
und die kommen wieder möglichst gut
vorbereitet und dann wird man sehen was
kommt
du machst jetzt den sport auch als profi
schon einige jahre bis der gleich nach
der ausbildung als maschinenbauer
konstrukteur zum herzsport gekommen und
wie es sich sozusagen als profi der
sport jetzt weiß man nach der uns
erklärt hast wie das alles abläuft mit
training und was da alles eine rolle
spielt dass es wichtig ist dass du da
profi bist du nicht auf den sport
konzentrieren kannst was kannst du aus
deiner grund ausbildungszeit oder aus
einer zeit als fairer sportler mitnehmen
für deinen sport wenn es dann auch in
die wettkämpfe hineingeht ich glaube
dass das bundesheer für jeden sport in
österreich ganz so wichtige rolle spielt
für ihn dass man grund versichert ist
dass man grundeinkommen hundertprozentig
unterschreibt und gesagt dass durch die
chance seit 2001 beim bundes jahr
das bundesheer hat man die möglichkeit
geben da sie als diskuswerfer wonach
dabei wird bei der nationalitäten im
bereich der metalle machen kann aber
gesagt du der lucke der kanal führung
ich möchte allen orten wohnen denn ist
wie jeder sportler ist sozusagen belag
sehen die investierten und dann
unterstützt bei den sportler und
deswegen findet das bundesheer brutal
wichtig weil die den sportler nehmen
unterstützen und schützen und schauen
dass er wirklich an weg zu den
olympischen spielen macht und dann
vielleicht zu beteiligen
und ich glaube dass man die so oft da
bisher unterschätzt weil das sozusagen
das fundament das waren jetzt zu hause
ist ist das bundesheer jemals als
fundament wo es dann um stehen ja dann
haben damals die zeit wo man wirklich
schaffen kann
mit trainer mit physio relations'
maßnahmen dann kommen die ersten
wettkämpfe und bundesheer ist ja immer
dabei und unterstützt stand und das ist
natürlich bitter hat sicherlich nicht
dasitzen waren sich einig nicht zu den
olympischen spielen schon manches bundes
harnik aber ich glaube so geht's eben
sportler der wo es nächstes jahr dann
anfliegen erstarkt nachdrucke und druck
geht es gar nicht darum was der der
ersten zeit beim bundesheer wo man das
dann hilft bei drucker sondern
ich glaube dass man das bundesheer fonds
und jetzt zum zum schluss wirklich
gefährlich spiele das historisch und
viel wichtiger wie wo sich der mann für
mich sind wirklich das fundament wo die
leistung aufbauen kann und damit ich
glaube das investment in die ist schon
voll aufgegangen aber das kann glaube
ich noch viel viel weiter aufgehen jetzt
sieht man das treiben so intensiviert
dich mit deinem sport auseinandersetzt
was macht der mensch lukas neben seinem
sport damit auch vielleicht ein
ausgleich hat vielleicht gerade das ganz
am anfang schon angesprochen dass du
gemerkt hast was wirklich wichtig ist in
dieser zeit was sind denn diese dinge
die für dich auch so ein bisschen das
zurückkommen sind du bist auch sehr
heimatverbunden das weiß man also was
machst du so in deiner freizeit wenn du
noch ein paar minuten freizeit hast am
tag kann man jetzt glauben dass stimmen
dass sie nicht vorgekommen waren
südstadt 3com von oberösterreich vom vom
innviertler und danke die costa sieht es
da schon angesprochen da man wirklich
ein rückzugsort braucht wo man wirklich
haben wir die batterien aufladen kann
oberhummer dame ist für eine brutal
wichtig die persönliche meiner freizeit
gern fischen
ich bin sehr leidenschaftlich fischer ja
auch mal dazwischen kurs gemacht und das
ist was man relativ für spaß mutter
wirklich gut abschalten kann und das ist
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
philosophisch aber ich finde wirklich
schäfer einfach am wasser stehe und das
plätschern her wo man die platte
vielleicht und her wog anstoß ist wo man
wirklich beim fliegenfischen sterben
sogar prozent wussten was da drinnen wo
die natur warum gibt dann wo die natur
mal die zeit vor gibt du hast nicht
lange eine sehr fischer sondern du musst
dir wirklich zeit nehmen und dort für
kraft sammeln batterien aufladen kraft
für die nächsten wettkämpfe oder für für
die sparte trennt und dann wieder
sammeln und natürlich familie wo es was
ganz wichtig ist wo man sehr viel
energie damit
hier wird der kleine nichte wo dank
corona der stimmung her eigentlich dran
gewesen wäre
bei ihrem geburtstag meistens eigentlich
waren wir dort auf trainingslager aber
gott gelobt haben noch vermissten aber
erst einmal bei der feier dabei die
sorge ist nicht viel gemein wie
persönlich dadurch wirklich signaturen
familie ist echt viel groove da sammeln
konnte war herr salzburger land
unterwegs und einer steiermark sogar
wahlgang hätte ja nicht mal von mir aber
das ist wohl so
also herr irrsinnig viel groove gehen
und das ist genau das was sie brauchte
für nächstes jahr dann folgt der
vorbereitung für die olympischen spiele
ist ja habe in der stadt auch
mitbekommen
eine art österreicher tour gemacht hast
du um abzuschalten um genau diese
aspekte die jetzt so genannte das doch
wirklich erleben zu können wird einem da
vielleicht auch vieles bewusst was man
so in der schnellen bewegten übervollen
athleten welt sonst nicht so mitbekommt
maximal auf die wettkämpfe vor
speziellen asiatischen teil unserer erde
merke dass wir in österreich wirklich
ein wunderschönes land haben jetzt wird
der nationalfeiertag und wie wir für
mich überhaupt man sich sehr stolz auf
österreich bin auf unser land bin und
ich glaube dass dann dazu die
österreicher unterschreiben dass man ein
wunderschönes land haben ich denke über
andere leute kommen so sehr als urlaub
mache also und habe es ja wirklich merkt
also die ganzen sehen was man haben dass
er wahnsinnig gemacht fotos und jetzt
kommt das postkarten verkaufen das ist
das wirklich abrutschen ins land und
dann kommt es denn in anderen ländern wo
wirklich die rede sein versichert auch
die straßen oder du merkst um die welt
ist nicht überall so schäfer bei uns und
das macht mir brutal streits um das man
wirklich dort am sand hat jasmin
österreich und
und sie findet die natur ist was ganz
schön unsere felle bewahren soll
und ja ich kann sagen die österreicher
war richtig richtig genossen harry oder
sogar ein camper aus licher wie sogar
wieder im camp marmal darum kann aber
wobei vielleicht sehen wir nur größter
nehmer übernahme war richtig polizei in
österreich ganz schönes land und ich
glaube das ist ein super schlusswort wir
sollten dankbar sein dafür dass wir in
diesem schönen land wohnen kann dieses
schöne land ist auch sehr stolz auf dich
und wir freuen uns auch auf die erfolge
mit denen sie uns ganz sicher noch
überraschen wir sind nicht jahren alles
gute viel gesundheit und tag erfolgte
danke dass du heute da was danke auch
fürs dabeisein
ich hoffe ihr seid auch beim nächsten
mal wieder mit dabei beim sport rapport
wo wir euch die tollen persönlichkeiten
hinter den vielen heraus sportlerinnen
und sportlern zeigen wollen und euch
näher bekannt machen wollen bis dann
bleibt gesund und auf wiedersehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]